will Donald Trump's brain appears to
have been broken by Ron DeSantis Trump
is now posting daily to truth Central
about it truth essential yeah truth
truth social now I'm calling it the
wrong thing uh truth truth social yes
not truth Central
um you know a few days ago Donald Trump
said he never thinks about Ron DeSantis
and that made me think that all Trump is
thinking about is Ron DeSantis and Trump
is now just posting daily about DeSantis
Trump is obsessed with a guy who hasn't
actually announced that he's running
against Trump yet let's take a look at a
couple of these posts every day it is
something here is one from a couple of
days ago Donald Trump posting quote so
interesting to watch Fox News cover the
small and unenthusiastic 139 person
crowd in Staten Island for DeSantis but
stay as far away as possible from
coverage of the thousands of people many
unable to get in at the club 47 event in
West Palm Beach Florida I call Fox News
the Rhino Network and their down big
ratings accurately reflect the name if
fake news CNN was smart which they're
not they'd go conservative and all Trump
all the time like in 2016 and become a
capital R ratings capital J Juggernaut
there are like 10 fascinating things
about this post and you have to
understand the context and kind of be
aware of the back story on a lot of
these things first and and foremost
Trump's continued obsession with crowds
DeSantis had 139 people I had thousands
Fox news is talking about that crowd
they're not talking about my crowd
that's bad secondly anything short of
complete brown-nosing and sucking up up
to Trump immediately gets you branded a
rhino if you're a republican who is
anything other than completely an
unflinchingly and blindly loyal to Trump
you're a rhino if you are a network and
you cover what a different Republican
did instead of what Trump did you are a
rhino and then lastly again Trump's idea
he's mentioned this a number of times
now that CNN could really do something
stunning if they were to become
conservative like Fox that everybody
would flock to CNN even after Trump has
been bashing CNN for the greater part of
a decade at this point in time
um and he's probably right I mean the
truth is if CNN became conservative and
Trump said CNN is the place to go I'm
sure that his followers who have spent
years talking about how CNN is some kind
of marxist satanic influence on American
society I'm sure they would just go over
there again remember Trump told us he's
not thinking about Ron DeSantis but he's
posting about Ron DeSantis every single
day
his next post quote Florida was doing
great long before Ron Des Sanctus got
there
uh people are fleeing by the way
the Sanctus is really funny I I know
that it went to first it was
dissanctimonious but I don't know if to
say this is a uh is a typo of Trump's
nickname for DeSantis or it's the next
Evolution but there is something funny
about that okay people are fleeing from
New York to Florida and other places
because of high taxes and out of control
crime not because of Governor thank you
president Trump to sanctimonious Rick
Scott did great and even Charlie Crist
had very good numbers sunshine and ocean
very alluring so I think the point Trump
is trying to make here is Florida is
great but it has nothing to do with
desanctus it's great because of the
sunshine and the ocean and the
um you know low no state income tax and
all this stuff I speaking of the taxes
and this is a tangent but I believe it's
an appropriate one if you will allow it
um when I talked last week about
oh am I moving to Florida and I said
well I'm not moving to Florida but it is
seeming pretty appealing to spend like
January and February in Florida and
avoid some of the Northeast you know
gray dark Winters or whatever some
people wrote in saying David I know
you're really talking about that because
you want to pay no state income tax now
the truth is if you live for two months
in Florida you know these northern
states New York Connecticut
Massachusetts they don't let you stop
paying income tax so I believe that you
have to spend like more at least more
than half the year in order to be able
to say I live in Florida but then other
people wrote to me and said David if
you're actually thinking about the
Florida thing because you want to avoid
state income tax they get you in other
ways because property taxes are very
high and other taxes are and all these
different that I don't even know if
that's true it's totally plausible to me
that maybe it's not actually cheaper tax
wise to live in Florida because you save
on state income but you pay I don't even
know I've not looked into it but it
wouldn't shock me if that were true as
far as the Sanctus
um Ron DeSantis isn't even running and
Trump is posting daily about him just
imagine what the next year is going to
be like if DeSantis does run and it
appears as though he is gearing up for
that one of our sponsors today is fume
fume is on a mission to accelerate
Humanity's breakup from the bad habits
that consume far too many of us
including ones that harm our health fume
is a natural diffusive device that uses
plants and Behavioral Science to trade
out your negative habit for a positive
one fume is not a vape it's a
non-electronic device designed to
transform your negative habits instead
of PODS filled with potentially harmful
chemicals like a vape fume uses cores
infused with plants like peppermint and
cinnamon for delicious natural flavors
fumes new version 2 model is Snappy and
tactile with an adjustable airflow dial
and a magnetic end cap that's fun to
fidget with its fume's goal to make
switching easy or even enjoyable they
have thousands of five star reviews from
people just like you who have
successfully switched when other
Solutions didn't work head to trifum.com
and use the code Pacman to get 10 off
today when you get the journey pack
which comes with three unique flavors
and the new version to fume the link is
down below